we already know that dlc is coming to
the division but there is still lots of
unanswered questions for one where does
the dlc take place well one youtuber
seems to have glitched his way into some
of the new areas could this be our first
look at the new content the first area
shown is DeWitt Park which is actually
populated with lots of objects like
benches and homes the second area is
Central Park which is pretty much what
you'd expect a glitched area to look
like mostly empty with a lot of blank
textures now the only question is
whether these parks are actually going
to be filled with content or if they
were just left over from the development
cycle we'll have to wait and see the
division certainly isn't the first game
to be cracked open like this plenty of
destiny players glitch their way into
unfinished areas to the divisions first
expansion called underground launches in
June so we'll have our answer then in
the meantime keep your sights on
gamespot for all the division news you
need
you